[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou allô oui Serge la main je vous le
passe tout de suite qui
c'est encore allô oui c'est moi oui oui
oui
[Musique]
j'arrive je fais au ciel qu je
fais pour tomber amour d'un être dont
les sens les sens ne sont
satisfait
après plusieurs heures de
bien-être je suis à plat je suis crevé
regarde et de nuit en nuit
[Musique]
jeo j'ai manger remanger je perds un kil
par
soirée je crois bien qu'
jamaises les
nuitses les
heuresa mon
auraisje un jour assez d'amis pour
juguler son
appétit auraisje un jour assez d'amis
pour apaiser des
[Musique]
insomnies tu sais que fa pas bon he pas
bon du tout de ne pas dormir près de sa
blombe et bien que je sois très jaloux
et ben j'aimerais parfois qu'on me
seconde
c'estes mentisent tous les soirs quand
sur ma bouche elle se
colle quand je pense qu'il y a des
veinards ils font sac le samedi soir
après des
carpentiers je crois bien qu'elle ne
dort
jamais vous savez que toutes les nuits
hein toutes les heures toc toc elle
frappe à mon
cœur
or un jour assez d'amis pour juguler son
appétit auraisje un jour assez d'amis
pour apaiser ses
insom le dimanche le dimanche c'est pire
encore il est pas question de matiner
grâce
elle s'occupe de mon petit corps jusqu'à
ce que je demande
grâce le lundi je suis
exténué et sur mon bureau je somle quand
je pense qu'il y a des cingl qui P qui P
pour voir ça au
ciné je crois bien qu'elle ne dort
jamais mais ce qui s'appelle
jamais toute la nuit tu m'entends toutes
les heures ce qu'elle fait elle VO pas
ton
cœur auraisje un jour assez d'amis pour
eux RUL son
appétit àoir ton sourire
réjoui il y a des
soirs j'ai bien peur que
oui quand même